-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are here with Catherine
Zeta-Jones.
And this is very exciting.
You mentioned that you're
playing Morticia Addams
in the fantastic new series
"Wednesday."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-With my co-star Fred.
-Yeah, Fred.
Fred is in it, as well,
as Uncle Fester.
And I would not --
Fred, I should stress,
I would not have thought
you'd be a perfect Uncle Fester
until I saw the photo.
I wasn't like --
In all the years I knew you,
I wasn't like, "Oh,
you should be a Fester one day,
but, my God, nailed it."
-Nailed it.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-Yeah. You guys did not have
any scenes together.
-No, we didn't,
but it was a real treat.
You know, I mean, a bit like
the show I'm working --
"National Treasure,"
it's like an iconic show that --
and characters like Fester
and Morticia that are really --
It's more than
pop culture, really.
They're, like, indelible.
They're in our subconscious.
My niece knows
"The Addams Family"
and Wednesday in particular.
And my grandmother,
God bless her soul,
sits on my shoulder.
She loved "The Addams Family."
So, it's -- And then,
you know, you throw in
the brilliant mind of Tim Burton
and the fantastic casting of
Jenna Ortega,
and, you know, you --
I'm just thrilled
that, you know,
it's done so well
and people are really
enjoying the work.
-Yeah, Jenna Ortega is amazing,
and for those who don't know,
it sort of is about Wednesday
going off to a boarding school.
-Yeah.
-So you're playing a mom who's
dropping the kids off at school.
You know, we were talking about
your kids a little bit.
Did it bring you back to
the first time
you sort of sent them away
to make their own lives?
-Yes. I mean, 'cause with
all the kind of iconic curves
and nuances that Morticia has.
She is the matriarch, you know?
And so
it was something wonderful
about playing that matriarch.
I was just a bawling wreck.
I was embarrassing when my kids
went off to college, you know?
You try and hold it together
and you tell them,
"Now, don't get upset."
And then, the next minute,
you're like a --
you know, a fool.
And, you know, you just --
Anyway, but it's amazing,
yeah, those milestones
in your life.
And, you know, with Jenna, this
mother-daughter relationship
is really crucial
to the whole show, you know?
-Well, people are
really responding to it.
And it's so cool,
it's so exciting
anytime Tim Burton
does something.
-I know.
-You were saying, you know,
you worked with Fred.
You guys were all in Romania
working on this.
But during the commercial break,
you were saying
you did not know
Fred played drums.
-No.
-And then you shared with us
that you were
a British tap champion.
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And tapping -- The reason why
I was saying to Fred,
'cause I didn't know
he played drums.
You know, he's got too much
talent in one body.
-Yeah.
-That's okay.
-But I dabble with drums,
I play piano, and I love music.
But when I tap-dance, it's
really like I'm playing drums.
And I always thought that if
I was in a band,
I would -- You know,
I wouldn't play drums.
I would just tap the rhythm.
But I'm waiting for a show where
I can tap-dance -- or a film.
-I mean,
we're throwing it out there.
-With "Chicago,"
I didn't get to tap.
I did think about if
I could slip it in somewhere.
But -- Yeah.
-What was the competition like
when you won
your British tap championship?
-Well, it was all
the dancing schools
from around the country,
and, you know,
you all kind of compete.
-Did you get nervous?
Do you get nervous
in the competition setting
when you were
a young tap dancer?
-I didn't get nervous
for anything when I was young,
but as soon as you reach kind of
15, 16, all of a sudden,
the older you get,
the more nervous I get.
I still get nervous
the first day of shooting.
But when I was a kid,
I didn't get nervous.
-Did your peer group
think tap was cool?
-Yeah.
-Oh, that's pretty awesome.
-Oh, yeah, they thought
it was very cool.
-Well, you grew up in Wales, and
I don't know if you ever heard,
Dylan Thomas once said
it was a musical nation.
-You just stole my line.
-I know that.
-You are so smart.
-That's a thing I know.
-You are so -- He is so smart.
You know, it's like,
nine years on the show,
I thought the brain cells
would have gone.
Nope.
-No, they're growing every year.
I just absorb information.
I heard there's one role
that got away from you,
which was Bond.
-I would have loved to
have played Bond.
-See? That's so exciting.
-Because, you know,
in Britain --
I guess it's in America, too.
"Doctor Who"
is really big, you know?
And we had a female Doctor Who,
and it was just like, "Yes!"
That should
have happened years ago.
But, anyway, I had such a
wonderful relationship
with Sean Connery.
I did a
movie called "Entrapment"
with him many, many years ago.
And he was like
my elder brother, my dad,
you know, my support.
I just really loved him,
and we talked.
I'm a Bond fanatic.
And, so, he said to me once,
"Yeah, you would have made
a great Bond Girl."
I went, "A Bond Girl or Bond?"
He went, "Bond...Girl."
I went, "Oh, my gosh.
I would have loved to
have played Bond."
But I think those --
that time has passed.
-Well, look, we are
lucky enough to see you
in everything as it comes out,
and we're so happy anytime
you show up, and it's just
wonderful to have you here.
Thank you so much, as always.
You guys, Catherine Zeta-Jones.
The first two episodes of
"National Treasure:
Edge of History"
premieres December 14th
on Disney+,
with new episodes
premiering Wednesdays.
We'll be right back with
Hong Chau.